uh Millie Bobby Brown has said that she
is a
feminist and she knows she is a feminist
because a psychic told her which to me
totally checks out because
psychics gain their dubious insights by
communing with demons so I'm not
surprised at all that a demon would
encourage anyone to become a feminist uh
in fact I think that's a large driver of
feminism probably you know at least at
least indirectly so I don't know I look
at a young actress in Hollywood and
she's been a child star which is
something that really messes virtually
everyone up and she's nevertheless said
I want to get married at a nice young
age not too young but 19 20 it's pretty
good get married young and start having
kids and I think okay I want to
encourage her that's great that's
awesome she's still surrounded by a
bunch of wackos in Hollywood who might
be influencing her with bad things like
feminism and psychics and whatever but
she she clearly has a a decent core
intuition here so she should follow that
and stop listening to Demons